On average, Earth orbits about 93 million miles from the sun.
An international team has now found a planet orbiting 650 times further than that,...
...leading astronomers to wonder how it exists at all?
11 times Jupiter's mass, the planet called "H D 106906 b"...
...orbits at 60 billion miles from its sun-like star.
The mysterious world is quite young, just 13 million years old, making it a puzzle.
Typically, researchers believe planets that orbit stars...
...are created from the gas, dust, and other debris around a young star...
...which would make such a distant, young formation impossible.
In this case, astronomers suspect the pair began forming as binary stars...
...but the planet never quite became a star itself.